if folks wanted to read what Jerry
Springer's reading why we mostly
political books right now I'm reading
July 1914 and I'm reading a lot on World
War one what is Jerry Springer watch on
TV what are you entertained by sport and
I'm a political junkie all the political
shows yeah yeah you know the right which
drives me crazy and the left which gives
me confidence you know it's all I watch
it all if Jerry Springer could be an
action hero batman or superman what
would it be superman because i'm not
going back to kryptonite I'm not you
know so I'll go back to the planet I'm
not going back to the planet so I think
I'm okay here super I'm when I was a
little boy Superman was one of the most
popular shows on television every
afternoon we come home from school and
we could see George Reeves in black and
money that half hour show Superman and
so I literally remember putting on my
Superman suit under my clothing and
going to school wearing it I was a
shortest kid in the class and I you know
I'm six feet now but when I was a child
I was really short I didn't start
growing really until college I was short
even graduating high school but anyway
so I was a little insecure with all that
thing so I would now I never went to the
phone booth or whatever but just it's
amazing i would go to school I feel okay
because the kids didn't know but
underneath I just pretended to be Clark
Kent
you